so you talk a lot about malevolence and
i've thought about it a lot and i think
about
these loops and patterns and the way
that we grew up i'm i wonder and maybe
the definition is important of of
malevolence and what you mean harm for
harm's sake so it's intentional it's
aware it's not only intentional the
person who's doing it knows it's wrong
they do it anyway so it's not by
accident this isn't the kind of
patterning or things like that that
drives someone to be reactive or
combative but they're really just
protecting themselves because of
something else going on
in their psyche or in their experience
this is someone who is
mean mean to be mean
yeah they're out to hurt
yeah well i think everybody's like that
some of the time
and some people are like that more often
than others i think one of the best
and we should talk a little bit about
more about self-awareness too because
we didn't quite finish that but
um
resentment can drive that
right
resentful you're not getting what you
want you won't admit what you want you
feel oppressed you feel that things
aren't going your way in an unfair way
that can make you want to hurt
it's very powerful motivation
and it's very unfortunate there's more
awareness there but is there not some
level of defense there
no there's revenge
it's more like revenge i mean look that
that defensive reaction occurs i'm not
i'm not denying that at all
so but
i wouldn't consider that malevolence
malevolence is i'm going to hurt you
even if i hurt myself doing it and maybe
if i hurt myself doing it so much the
better
oh i've had that on the racetrack before
ah no doubt no doubt of course of course
well and you know if you want to hurt
your parents that's the right way to do
it you hurt them and yourself
and if you don't think people to do that
you just don't know anything about
people i mean
people will do that there's a deep
streak of that capability within us
so
so i i i started to understand this a
little bit
in many different ways but you know in
in the story of of adam and eve
adam and eve open their eyes
right their eyes are open when they eat
the fruit of the tree of
knowledge of good and evil
their eyes are open they notice that
they're naked
and that's when they learn about good
and evil i thought why in the world how
does that make sense their eyes are open
they see that they're naked that makes
sense that that's associated with vision
why would that be associated with the
knowledge of good and evil
well nakedness is vulnerability you
talked about vulnerability
well
malevolence exploits vulnerability
so once i know that i'm vulnerable
i know how to hurt you
right i can use it
and i do think that's something very
specific to human beings i mean animals
hurt each other chimpanzees tear each
other apart
but human beings can be unbelievably
calculated in their use of brutality
and that's because we know what hurts
we have imagination for that and then we
can use it and it's part of being
self-conscious
it's a it's a it's a catastrophic
consequence of being self-conscious you
can think of it that way
so because if i want to imagine how to
hurt you i just have to think well what
would really hurt me if i was in her
situation
and bang i've got it
and i think that's
in some sense it's defensive you know
because people are often driven to
resentment by suffering that they can't
tolerate
can't attribute meaning to
but
it passes a line
you know when you start adding to it
right
so
and that's something that needs to be
checked and checked in all of us
is there a reason or
any statistical
research that shows what makes one more
malevolent than another which
or uses uh hurts other people more
well you said second you said um a
hundred times more likely to be
step parent
abused yeah yeah well alcohol does
certainly alcohol being drunk
oh yes i mean alcohol alcohol is a very
bad drug for violence
50 of people who are murdered are drunk
and 50 of the people who murder them are
drunk and that's true for almost every
violent crime in fact if you eliminated
alcohol you'd eliminate most
interpersonal violence
look i i find that this is kind of an
interesting topic because i i think it's
interesting that alcohol is legal
and
yet you know you get
you you do terrible things
sometimes you probably couldn't you
probably couldn't have made any a worse
drug legal
right from an epidemiological
perspective on the other hand you have
marijuana or
um
[Music]
psilocybin or
lsd even or some of these other drugs
and they make you thirsty
make you laugh and you wake up feeling
fine i find it really fascinating that
alcohol is the illegal one how did that
ever happen at that or is the legal one
how did
why does ourselves i think it probably
happened because it was so easy to make
and it was just everywhere
right because all you really have to do
is put barley in water and you get beer
right so it was really easy to make and
at least
in many societies it's been around for a
very long time and so it became legal
just because well back in the middle
ages people drank alcohol not water
because all the water was polluted
right right right so
so that's the reason but it certainly
wasn't a consequence of evaluating the
drugs by their comparative risk and rank
ordering them and making you know the
least harmful legal it wasn't that at
all
because alcohol is unbelievably
dangerous i mean about 10 of people
become addicted to it one way or another
really far more people than that abuse
it yes at least once in their life yes
yeah it's really bad i studied alcohol
for years it was my
subject of my phd
oh my goodness so
do you believe that um are you a fan of
the legalizations that have happened
with marijuana and the things that i
don't see that making them illegal has
worked
and i don't think there's good evidence
that legalizing them has had detrimental
consequences
right i mean we legalized marijuana in
canada just before the pandemic
so the marijuana stores were open
through the whole bloody pandemic
weirdly enough
but
i mean in in terms of interpersonal
aggression
marijuana doesn't even register compared
to alcohol as as a social danger now i'm
not saying that it's without its harm i
mean i've i've had friends who i think
were
tilted towards psychosis because of
marijuana and there's some evidence that
it's use if you're predisposed to
psychosis can
can
exacerbate that tendency now he he may
have used it to self-medicate so i can't
say that it was necessarily the cause
but it looked to me like it wasn't good
and i saw lots of people when i was a
kid for whom pot wasn't good
i saw some for whom it was good
but
many it wasn't it changed them a lot and
not for the better as far as i was
concerned so what do you think of the
therapeutic side of um
things like psilocybin and the things
that mdma psilocybin that's its own
monster god only knows about psilocybin
yeah i i just
no one has any idea what that is
so i don't know what to say about lsd is
the same sort of thing it's like those
drugs are so far beyond our
comprehension that i mean it takes
almost no lsd it's the most powerful
pharmacological substance ever
discovered takes a couple hundred
million molecules which is really none
at all to to put you somewhere
completely else
it's it's it's unbelievably powerful
those drugs dmt psilocybin lsd they're i
think they're the biggest mystery there
is as far as i can tell right now i
don't think there's anything we
understand less than those drugs
marijuana is sort of in that category
because it's a quasi hallucinogen
but
it's not the same sort of thing as dmt
or psilocybin or lsd masculine
i mean i know that dmt has been called
like the spirit molecule right so
yeah people regularly report you know
encounters with other beings when they
when they take dmt much to the chagrin
and shock of the people studying them
so there's just no one has any idea how
to account for it so it's hard to
account for whether or not there's a
benefit or not to it well
that's a different story to some degree
there was a large scale study done
population level study of hundreds of
thousands of people who had either used
psychedelics or who hadn't
and the ones who had used them at least
once were healthier by almost every
marker
now that doesn't mean necessarily that
you could attribute it to the
psychedelics because there might have
been other differences between the
populations but there certainly was no
evidence that the psychedelic use had
made those people worse
and then roland griffiths and his crew
in at johns hopkins who were doing very
careful studies of psilocybin
have shown that it's extraordinarily
powerful
mechanism for helping people quit
smoking and for overcoming their fear of
death if they have cancer which is
no one you know
why does it help them overcome their
fear well that's a deep mystery that's a
very very deep mystery